my name is george moats my job is to
make sure you appreciate the regional
american burger that's right
the regional burger what you may or may
not know is that there are many many
regional styles out there the slug
burger
the goober burger the deep fried burger
the oklahoma fried onion burger the
butter burger let's have some fun with
hamburger history let's do it
[Music]
i'm sure a deep fried burger sounds like
some kind of stunt burger but actually
no this burger has dna that goes all the
way back to the beginning the dawn of
the burger age in the beginning there
were no flat tops if you want to cook a
burger you had to get a skillet they
would deep fry a paper paper thin piece
of raw beef places like dyers have a big
piece of marble in the back where they
smash out their burgers
and they press out the beef so it's
paper thin
like a brick layer then you have to
gently get this thing off of here
and slip it into the oil
and that's it
what's really cool about this process
deep frying a burger
is lightening fast this will be done in
a matter of seconds look at that it's
already done they do a dyers they get
the cheese on the burger what they
actually do is they put the cheese right
on there and they give it a nice slow
dip back into the grease okay
slice of onion some pickles i'm gonna
make a double
in the beginning it was really just
mustard onion and pickle the deep fried
burger one of the original american
hamburgers still can be found in certain
spots in the midwest
[Music]
mmm oh my god look at that see that
those crispy bits look at that
where'd he get in there get that
go deep
you ready for this the butter burger
it's exactly what it sounds like
it's a burger with nothing more than
butter on it that's it just butter this
burger comes from wisconsin according to
the wisconsin state legislature in
section
section 9818 subsection 4 the serving of
margarine at a public eating place as a
substitute for butter
is prohibited punishable by a fine of up
to 500 or imprisonment you can go to
jail in wisconsin if you try to serve
somebody anything but butter in the
restaurant that's how seriously they
take it now wisconsin what they do
especially at sally's they take the top
of the bun right this has been toasted
and they put a very
large almost two to three tablespoon
dollop of butter on the burger this
seems ridiculous i know but the minute
that that
semi-soft butter hits that hot patty
[Music]
boom
once that melted butter starts to escape
onto the plate as you take bites you dip
the burger back into the plate for more
butter
look butter
bite
slug burger the slug burger exists in a
very very tiny part of the country
specifically in northern mississippi
hard times leading up to the great
depression meant people had to use
inventive ways to
extend their food supply when it came to
a hamburger restaurant that meant taking
yesterday's bread stale bread crushing
it up and putting it into today's beef
supply thereby extending the beef supply
was a very ingenious way to make the
meat last for many many days let's cook
beef
so there are no slugs in this burger in
case you hope maybe you're hoping for
slugs the name actually comes from the
old term friend nickel because these
burgers used to cost a nickel they would
say give me a slug
so all i'm doing is combining the meat
and the bread crumbs that's it don't put
anything else in here no seasoning
nothing i have a ball of beef
it's breadcrumbs it's high heat
it's beef it's some salt wow it's so
crunchy a little bit of mustard some
pickles and that's it i'm using a very
uncomplicated white bun because that's
honestly what would have happened 100
years ago this burger goes back to the
dawn of the hamburger age
the goober burger from missouri
unfortunately the place that i learned
about the goober burger has closed
moment of silence
yeah that sucks
the wheel in drive-in of sedalia
missouri was a place that served the
goober burger a peanut butter covered
burger when you put these things
together
beef flavor
peanuts
salty a little bit of sweetness in there
peanut oil
nut oils
these actually go a long way in creating
an amazing flavor profile let's make one
ready we're going to toast bun
smash burger
subtle salt salty bowls
all right inappropriate but smash
it's just hot
store-bought peanut butter that's all it
is
flip
then goober what they do is they
actually goober it right on the flat top
so i'm gonna dope the bun with some
pickles
yes
the goober burger from sedalia missouri
oh wow
[Music]
have you ever had peanut butters and
pickles
that is worth it
oh so good the oklahoma fried onion
burger okay it sits in the center of
what i like to call the burger belt of
america there are some of the best
burgers in america can be found from
texas south all the way north to
wisconsin minnesota okay and so of
course that makes oklahoma the buckle
right it makes perfect sense because
some of the best primary source
hamburgers can be found in oklahoma
right unaffected by time trend anything
the trick to the oklahoma front on your
burger is thin sliced onion if you're
making onion juice just go one step
further than you've got almost where you
can see through the thing
you get a scoop of meat right put it in
the pan
a little bit of salt
here's here's the cool part watch this
ready
[Music]
look at how much onion yeah yeah
it'll reduce okay
all of the onion juice will actually
render out you need a heavy spatula
because this thing has to be smashed
we had it on this side for maybe a
minute and a half
we always do cheese on flip this is
something that i do myself always
this all rides it's all becoming uh sort
of a hamburger config
yeah yeah yeah this is just like a bunch
of burger magic happening exactly again
you're biting into history there it's a
very important part of american all it's
like ugly beautiful
[Music]
wow i'm like the sum is greater than its
parts oklahoma yeah knows what they're
doing
the value of appreciating a regional
burger like this is that you get to go
back in time and experience what
somebody may have experienced a hundred
years ago
[Music]
sorry
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here somewhere in here right
there
yeah watch more episodes right here